[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'd like to thank you
for helping "The Dev Show"
get to its 50th episode.
Thank you.
Please keep clicking and
sharing so we can bring you
another 50 updates about
the coolest developer news
from Google.
Here's this last week.
We recently rolled
out the final update
to the Android 7.1
Developer Preview.
It includes the developer
features already available
on Pixel and Pixel XL devices,
and adds optimizations and bug
fixes on top of the base
Android 7.1 platform.
For more information
on what's included,
check out the post linked
in the description below.
The Google Maps APIs
have several services
that you can use to
convert addresses into
coordinates-- the Geocoding API,
the Place Autocomplete Service
and Places API, and the Place
Search service in Places API.
To better understand the
differences between them
and when you should use each
one, take a look at the post.
We introduced the next
generation of universal app
campaigns to help you show your
apps to the iOS and Android
customers that matter most
based on your specific business
goals.
Now we've got new innovations
to make your holiday app
campaigns more
engaging and effective,
covering immersive
video ads, new ways
to showcase your
app on Google Play,
and using Play data
to find users who
are likely to make a purchase.
Details are on the post.
And while you're
at it, check out
some Display Ads
innovations, as well,
including catalog
experiences with Gmail ads,
and responsive ads.
Chrome will soon mark
non-secure pages containing
password and credit
card input fields
as Not Secure in the URL bar.
You should really update your
site to avoid this warning.
For some help with that,
check out this post.
Firebase App Indexing
for Personal Content
lets users find personal content
like messages, notes, music,
and more across apps like Open
Table, Ticketmaster, Evernote,
and Gmail from a
single search box.
And now, it's available
to all Android developers.
Starting with version 10.0,
the Firebase App Indexing API
on Android lets you
add your app content
to Google's on-device
index in the background,
and update it in real time as
users make changes in the app.
Getting started is easy, and
the details are on the post.
You can now start using
Firebase Test Lab for Android
at no charge.
Head on over to the post
to get started today.
By creating a set of
declarative templates,
Google Cloud Deployment
Manager lets you consistently
deploy, update, and delete
resources like Google Compute
Engine, Google Container Engine,
Google BigQuery, Google Cloud
Storage, and Google Cloud SQL.
It's a great way to
manage and automate
your cloud environment.
And this is an awesome post
with lots of links and code
that will help you get started.
We're excited to announce that
Google Compute Engine will
support Intel's latest
custom cloud solution based
on the next generation
Xeon Processor-- code named
Skylake-- in early 2017.
The upcoming Xeon Processor
is an excellent choice
for graphics
rendering, simulations,
and any CPU-intensive workload.
If you'd like to be notified of
upcoming beta testing programs,
fill out the form linked on the
post in the description below.
Don't forget to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and I'll see
you next week with episode 51.
And as a bonus, here's a
look the last 50 episodes.
This is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
OK, if you're as excited as I
am, this first link is for you.
Android N is now available.
It's got a simple
interface, and, well, cats.
Lots and lots of cats.
OK, cool.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We tried recording the
show from the airplane,
but they just weren't having it.
This week, I'm at
AnDevCon in Boston.
From the Highline
in New York City.
Tokyo.
Berlin.
The YouTube space in LA.
Well, that was fun.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And I'm here with Magnus.
Hi, Magnus.
MAGNUS: Hey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: I don't think
there's any job in the world
that you're working with
more optimistic people who
are trying to solve
amazing problems.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And I'm
standing here with Mary Grove.
So Chad Haase is here.
Here with Dion and Ben.
Hello, gentlemen.
Hello, Mr. Pete LePage.
PETE: Hello, Mr. Timothy Jordan.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
With my buddy Josh.
Dan Shapiro.
Johnny Lee.
Eric Johnson.
Ian.
MAGNUS: Yes, that's correct.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
I want to hug it.
Do you want to hug it?
MAGNUS: It's amazing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[CHEERING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Tune
In during your commute,
the gym, mowing the lawn,
cooking dinner, or wherever.
You know that we're all really
excited about machine learning.
I have just a few
updates to share.
So let's see how fast I
can get you back to work.
With a tornado of fish.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Goodbye to Canvas hacks
and animated GIFs.
Yes, I said GIF.
Let's just move on.
OK, if you're as excited as I
am, this first link is for you.
Don't forget to subscribe,
because subscribing is caring.
And that's our show.
Hello, I'm Timothy
Jordan, and this
is your update about the
coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
We've partnered with Udacity to
create the VR developer Nano.
When you take the course,
you learn how to create--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of "The Developer
Show."
For some of our past
episodes, click here.
Or here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]